-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That is fantastic to hear.
Let's get to the news.
When asked why
he had not invited
President-Elect Joe Biden
to yesterday's
coronavirus vaccine summit
President Trump said
that the election
was still being decided.
Oh, buddy, buddy, it's decided
The only decision left now i
Bekins or Mayflower.
During his speech
yesterday at the
Operation Warp Speed
Vaccine Summit,
President Trump called
the new coronavirus vaccines
a "medical miracle."
Dude, just
'cause you don't know how
it works doesn't mean
it's a miracle.
Scientists around the worl
have been working day and nigh
for a year, and you're like,
"It's a miracle, like how
planes stay in the sky."
Vice President Mike Pence
traveled today
to Cape Canaveral, Florida
I assume to book a flight out.
"Hi. Yes, I need to be off thi
planet by Inauguration Day."
President Trump's election
lawyer Jenna Ellis
has reportedly tested positive
for coronavirus
just days after she was seen
visiting a wet market.
Ally Hord, thank you.
[ Laughs ]
That's right --
President Trump's lawyer
Jenna Ellis has reportedly
tested positive for
the coronavirus.
But don't worry.
She'll still be able to
lose cases remotely.
Health officials in Russia
have warned citizens
to avoid alcohol for
two months after receiving
the coronavirus vaccine.
Said citizens, "No problem."
A food company in
the Philippines
recently broke
a Guinness World Record
by making a 20-foot-tall
Christmas tree
out of 70,000 cans of sardines
or, as their cat calls it, God
According to a new study,
sports can be a good form
of therapy for boys
with behavioral problems.
Another good option?
Therapy.
And, finally, the New York Pos
has published an article
about a Manhattan Chipotle
that is "besieged by rats,
or, as New York City
health inspectors call it,
a "B."
It's for "besieged."
That's what the "B" is for
That was a monologue, everybody.